you know what i i get terrified of when
i do stand up what being corny
no
i don't even care about that
when i do stand up
i um
i get terrified of the idea
but i'm like almost too comfortable
but i stopped actually
being creative or stopped trying
you know but that's just that's just
that fear's
not um
i feel like that's almost like the
absence of what i love about standard
what i love about standup is the
spontaneity it's the
interaction and the connection with the
audience when i'm just there and i'm
doing old rehashed material that i know
works and i'm getting like this
inorganic relationship with the
audience like that's what i hate even
when i'm doing well with that stuff i'm
like
it's time to move on and i haven't done
it
and i'm letting my fear motivate me
rather than my love for standard
my fear of failure is what's motivating
me right now rather than my love of
seeing them but i'm doing well
they're they're laughing and i'm they're
like i hate this
all right so that's what might matters
it's just an explanation of what the
feeling that you have
because you're still gonna do your
reaction thing what you mean while
you're doing it and you're like oh i
hate that
you're still doing it it motivates you
in what sense and not doing it later on
you're doing it
the fact that you're doing that rehash
set or whatever
you're doing it now it's going to
motivate you of your fear is going to
motivate you of
doing what to just keep doing that
it stagnates you
i think you got to be brave
and i mean i think i think loving
something requires you to be brave to
have some courage
not to just be comfortable
requires you to be uncomfortable
actually oh yeah
that's what loving something requires if
you be it a person be it family you know
like
yeah
and so
i think when you're motivated by that
then yeah i think you're probably on the
right path more than anything i think
i think fear for me is a great motivator
when you are in crisis
like um
i think it's absolutely necessary and
it's normal to have
um
but i think once you're out of that i
think you need to have different
motivations
because like when you're thinking about
survival yeah fear is reminding you that
there's real imminent danger it's like a
it's a byproduct of human evolution like
almost any evolution that's absolutely
necessary can't live in a [ __ ]
dangerous area and not have fear like no
fear is like your body basically telling
you like there's danger
good sensible fear right so you have to
have a good sense of that right you need
to have a good sense of that to be able
to move through the world but after you
pass that threshold after you get out of
that [ __ ] thing it's like all right i
gotta live with something else
like [ __ ] you can't be in a gated
community motivated by your fear like
you gotta you gotta be good like like
you gotta you gotta live on something
else at some point you know what i'm
saying you gotta you made it out
right and that's why like some [ __ ]
make it out but they still
in that hot and then that's right and
[ __ ] them up yeah they've never been
able to let go and that's what i'm
saying when i'm saying like that when
the fear is too much
and it overpowers you and then you have
ptsd and stuff like that and becoming an
opposition it's like how you gonna be
rich rich not hire security and walk
with a
illegal firearm with you yeah
it's like but they're still stuck in
that yeah they're still stuck in that
insecurity that fear uh but and they do
that yeah this they're stuck in their
way so saying it goes with what you were
saying it's not because you reach a
certain level they reach that certain
level of not being
broke anymore right but it doesn't mean
that they're able to function and
they're not
because they still have those same
mannerism those same those same uh
things that they were doing the same
train of thoughts
as when they were broke that broke
mentality and they walk up in the spot
with an illegal firearm and then they
catch a case
[Music]
yeah
this whole conversation i feel like is a
metaphor for like human civilization and
evolution right because in the beginning
we're like motivated by a crisis of fear
like running from a tiger or whatever
wow and then eventually we're able to
settle and have agriculture and whatever
and then the motivate you know once
we kind of conquered the natural world
to a certain extent the motivation
motivations became different you know
like you have to move beyond that crisis
but i guess crisis is relative too you
know
it's like that's fair is it just an
immediate fear or
you know even if you're comfortable
even if you feel like you've gotten past
that crisis mode where you're motivated
purely by imminent fear
there's still things that can kind of
push you backwards or go wrong you know
there's still a little bit of
yeah you know
of something pulling you away where you
don't want to look down you know or
whatever
yeah
yeah well that was my week
my last couple weeks just thinking about
[ __ ]
god damn that's brutal